irish is a different language
[Music]
tag what who could forget it
todd digger tag todd
oh i didn't see that coming rochin
uh oh we got one of those weird symbols
but i never knew what to do with in a
way that you wouldn't expect
raisin rizwin rosen rosine
ryzen roshine
so what does that symbol do searsha
this one i should know because there's
an actress
that has this name and she was in the
west anderson movie these combination of
letters
is just so strange char say sarosi
swearsie sweersia siersha
these are really pretty names but
they're spelled so weird
kiva guys you tell me what you do with
an eminent h
because i'm at a loss this looks like
portuguese ciao
me maybe it's just simple maybe it's
just
kaomi kami kiva
i'm sorry what there's a v in there owen
some of these letters are not being used
it's just me figuring out which ones
egan totally eagen uh johann you're gone
ethan eugene i give up owen
no why is the e in there if it has no
purpose
if there's no e and owen okay there is
never mind
merade i don't know what the little
thing is above the e
is it my red may read so i think it
would be
my read but it's probably like varied
murdered married married what is that
it's like a
it's like a male parade i don't even
know what
a's are anymore nev
this name is just name yeah
naomi nieum like liam but it's an n
niam nim like uh the mice
neo i'm sorry what i am
not getting that from this grana
this is a term of endearment for your
grandmother granny i don't know how else
to pronounce
it other than grainy gr grayini gr
griny there's literally no other way to
say this
and if they say it a different way it's
wrong it's grain
what is it grania that's beautiful
i feel like they can make a big comeback
in like a hipster way
which the irish better watch out that's
not to say
that irish names are confusing i just
find language confusing
i can barely speak english